[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönborn herzlich Willkommen an
diesem Sonntag mittag schön dass Sie
dabei sind am Ende einer Woche von der
wir wohl erst im Rückblick irgendwann
wissen werden ob sie uns dem Ende dieses
russischen angriffskriegs in der Ukraine
ein Stück näher gebracht hat oder ob Sie
eine neue Eskalationsstufe in diesem
Krieg markiert die Entscheidung dieser
Woche die Bundesrepublik wird zusammen
mit europäischen NATO-Partnern rund 90
Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
liefern Bundeskanzler Scholz hat dem
Drängen aus Kiew von dem Druck der
Partner nachgegeben aber er hat auch
durchgesetzt dass sich die Amerikaner
später im Jahr mit eigenen
Panzerlieferungen beteiligen nur einen
Tag nach Scholz Erläuterungen im
Bundestag nimmt die nächste Debatte
Fahrt auf reicht es der Ukraine Kampf
Gegensatz zu liefern wenn sie doch auch
Kampfjets braucht um ihre Linien zu
verteidigen über all dem steht die große
Frage was muss der Westen tun um die
Ukraine in ihrer Verteidigung zu
unterstützen was kann er tun ohne
selbstpartei dieses Krieges zu werden
ich freue mich auf diese Gäste Sabine
Adler ist wieder bei uns sie ist
osteuropaexpertin beim Deutschlandfunk
herzlich willkommen Tina Hildebrandt
Chefin des Politik Ressorts bei der
Wochenzeitung Die Zeit ich freue mich
auf Moritz Eichhorn er leitet das
Politik Ressort der Berliner Zeitung und
Matthias Gebauer ist bei uns Chef
Reporter beim Spiegel Herr Gebauer
lassen Sie uns doch bitte mit der Frage
anfangen die ich eingangs gestellt habe
bringt uns diese Woche dem Ende des
Krieges ein Stück näher was bedeutet
diese Entscheidung
also ich tue mich mit so welchen
Prognosen immer sehr schwer wir haben
alle glaube ich mehrmals schon falsch
gelegen
gleichwohl denke ich dass die
Entscheidung schon eine Art Wende
darstellt und zwar eher erstmal
politisch der Westen hat sich
durchgehoben wenn auch mit Hakeleien
sozusagen noch mal einen deutlichen
Schritt nach vorne zu gehen deutlich
modernere Waffen zu liefern das an sich
öffnet aus meiner Sicht ein Tor für
weitere Lieferungen ob es zu einer
wirklichen Wende in der Ukraine kommt
das ist glaube ich sehr schwer zu
prognostizieren weil man auch nicht weiß
wie die Russen reagieren werden wenn man
das rein militärisch sieht haben sie
jetzt ungefähr zwei panzerbataillone die
bis Ende März aufgestellt werden und in
die Ukraine
geliefert werden
aus militärischer Sicht würde man sagen
mit einem Panzerbataillon kann man circa
fünf vielleicht etwas mehr Kilometer an
einer Frontlinie abdecken daran erkennen
sie schon die Front die die an sich ist
mehrere 100 Kilometer lang das heißt an
Schwerpunkten wie jetzt zum Beispiel in
bachmut wird man sicherlich mit dieser
panzerlieferung auch militärisch
taktisch etwas ändern aber ob es an der
gesamten Frontlinie eine richtige Wende
also dieses wo man von der spricht das
ein Game changer ist das bleibt glaube
ich noch abzuwarten weil sie ihre
Einschätzung politischer Wendepunkt hat
der Gebauer gesagt teilen Sie das
Wendepunkt nicht aber Zäsur ist es
glaube ich schon ich glaube schon dass
man sie haben gesagt wir werden später
erst wissen was das für einen Moment war
das liegt ja in der Natur der Sache aber
ich glaube ich habe schon das Gefühl das
ist ein nachdem nach der Zeiten wenn
Rede von Olaf Scholz bezogen auf
Deutschland ist das ein ein
definierender Moment in diesem Konflikt
und ich glaube dass er Grundproblem ist
ja ob etwas in ein richtiges Instrument
ist weiß man ja immer nur im Hinblick
auf ein Ziel und das ist glaube ich ein
Grundproblem in diesem Konflikt das eben
die Ziele nicht beschrieben sind ich
glaube sie können auch gar nicht also es
gibt gute Gründe dafür dass sie nicht
beschrieben werden können aber deswegen
ist es natürlich immer ein bisschen
schwierig wenn man sich die Frage stellt
reicht das denn es ist immer die Frage
für wen und wofür aber ich glaube man
kann auf jeden Fall sagen dass das jetzt
noch mal eine neue Stufe ist ein
Wendepunkt würde ich nicht sagen denn es
liegt ja in der Linie dass immer mehr
Waffen liefern das mit dem Ziel nehme
ich mal mit in den Hinterkopf sollten
wir später auf jeden Fall noch drauf
eingehen Frau Adler ein politischer ein
militärischer Wendepunkt
ich würde auch sagen es ist eine neue
Qualität in der Partnerschaft in der
transatlantischen Partnerschaft dann ist
es jetzt klar die USA sind über einen
Kniff über einen Jungen Tim wie auch
immer wieder das bezeichnen wollen von
Olaf Scholz tatsächlich in die Pflicht
genommen worden sie haben sich auch in
die Pflicht nehmen lassen und das
bedeutet eben auch dass dieses sie haben
sich nicht zurückgezogen darauf dass sie
ohnehin das meiste liefern und schon das
meiste machen sondern sie haben sich
jetzt noch mal mehr verpflichtet und
also sich so einbinden zu lassen das
nicht zurückzuweisen zu sagen wir haben
schon gemacht und wir entscheiden selbst
sondern sich wirklich vor aller Welt
haben einbinden zu lassen
mit Europa zusammen in diesem Krieg
zusammenzustehen das finde ich schon
eine neue Qualität
ich nutze die Gelegenheit Danke zu sagen
bei allen die sich schon in sozialen
Netzwerken und auf presseclub.de
beteiligen an unserer Debatte ja und
auch da wird in vielen Worten die Frage
gestellt ist das etwas was uns dem Ende
des Kriegs näher bringt oder ist das
Risiko die Gefahr jetzt noch viel größer
geworden
ich glaube es hat auf jeden Fall den
Wendepunkt verhindert dass der Krieg
sich zugunsten von Russland drehen
könnte denn jene vermutete
Frühjahrsoffensive mit der ja gerechnet
wird um die zumindest zurückhalten zu
können dafür verlangen die Ukraine ja
nach diesen Panzern ich glaube es wird
teilweise auch viel zu wenig von
militärischen her erklärt sondern immer
wieder eigentlich über
Hintergrundgespräche und Allianz
sozusagen Verstärkung und wie können wir
mit den Amerikanern und die Frage ist
doch was wird auf dem Schlachtfeld
eigentlich gebraucht und erklärt sich
das nicht dadurch es hat sicherlich eine
neue Qualität aber ich glaube auch in
der Hinsicht dass die Versprechung die
Ukraine werde so lange unterstützt wie
sie es benötigt damit eingelöst werden
und ich fand interessant was ich aus der
SPD ähm gehört zum Beispiel von Frau
esken vergangene Woche die auf die Frage
nach den Kampfjets angesprochen sagte es
gibt keine roten Linien auch nicht beim
Bundesgrenze
ich habe eine Frage gerade im Kopf weiß
gar nicht ob sie jemand beantworten kann
also das Versprechen werde eingelöst die
Ukraine bekommt was sie benötigt haben
sie gerade betont wir hatten eine
wochenlange Diskussion und man stellt
sich natürlich schon die Frage die
Frühjahrsoffensive der Russen kann bald
beginnen die Panzer werden passt nicht 8
Wochen brauchen um dort zu sein
während die Dinge anders wenn die
Entscheidung vor ein zwei drei Monaten
schon getroffen worden wäre das kann ich
ich bin auch kein Militärexperte nicht
genau sagen ich denke es ergibt sich
einfach sehr viel mehr aus den
Bedürfnissen auf dem Schlachtfeld als
wir das vielleicht direkt in der Debatte
erleben die Ukraine bitten und
irgendwann finden Sie wirklich und
irgendwann wird das dann auch noch mal
vielleicht von amerikanischen geheimen
Diensten sozusagen begründet so würde
ich mir das eher vorstellen aber
wobei dieses brauchen und wünschen
natürlich auch limitiert ist denn das
ist ja eine Entscheidung die im Prinzip
am Anfang gefallen ist als ähm die
Ukraine einen Flugverbotszone gefordert
hat und die der besten gesagt hat das
machen wir nicht und damit war
impliziert die Aussage verbunden der der
sagen wir mal der Zielpunkt oder das
prioritätsmerkmal Nummer eins ist nicht
das was die Ukraine braucht sondern es
ist genau das was Sie beschrieben haben
immer dieses feine ausloten wie können
wir verhindern dass sich der die
Geschichte zu Gunsten von Russland
wendet und wie weit können wir gehen
aber das wird in der Debatte ja immer
wird gerne argumentiert mit was die
Ukraine braucht und das ist
offensichtlich nicht der das einzige
Kriterium was da maßgeblich ist und zwar
nicht nur für Olaf Scholz sondern für
alle Verbündeten ja ich versuch's einmal
noch ergeben ist Schaden entstanden das
nicht schon vor drei Monaten das Signal
gegeben wurde ich würde der schon sagen
denn wir haben ja gesehen dass seit dem
Sommer für die russischen Streitkräfte
eigentlich nicht viel zu gewinnen war
also es hat tatsächlich einen eine
festgefahrene Situation gegeben im
dornbas es gab überhaupt keine
erweiteren Eroberung andere Seite aber
andererseits auch keine Rückeroberungen
und hätte
das ist jetzt natürlich schon wie man
den Satz anfängt hätte ist schon doof
aber ich mache ihn trotzdem weiter also
hätte die Ukraine über Panzer verfügt
über mehr Panzer verfügt wäre sie
möglicherweise in der Lage gewesen diese
Eroberungen schneller zurückzuschlagen
schneller Rückeroberungen zu machen und
dieses sich sortieren müssen von
ukrainischer Seite von russischer Seite
tatsächlich auszunutzen für sich diesen
Moment für sich zu nutzen und dass
dieser wirklich gute Moment der nicht
für für einen kurzen Moment nur Bestand
sondern tatsächlich über eine ganze Zeit
dass dieser so verstreichen musste das
ist eigentlich aus ukrainischer Sicht
wirklich schade ich gebe Ihnen noch die
Frage eines Users mit wenn der Westen
jetzt mehr Waffen an die Ukraine
geliefert wird Russland mit noch mehr
Waffen kontern
erstmal kurz zu der ersten Frage ist
Schaden entstanden aus meiner Sicht des
Schaden deswegen entstanden weil man die
politische Entscheidung nicht richtig
vorbereitet hat und das finde ich ein
bisschen enttäuschend nicht nur von der
Bundesregierung dass sie nicht früh
genug
mit der Industrie gesprochen hat einfach
Dinge hat vorbereiten lassen die Panzer
schon mal aufbereiten lassen
möglicherweise mit dem Training schon
ein bisschen anfangen ich höre natürlich
immer wieder das hätten wir nicht machen
können weil damit hätten wir eine
politische Entscheidung vorweggenommen
das sehe ich in so einer Kriegslage
anders in der Kriegslage in der wir im
Moment sind nicht als Beteiligter aber
wir haben diesen laufenden Konflikt
musst du auch Dinge vorbereiten die du
mögliche also sozusagen Karten
vorbereiten die du am Ende nicht siehst
und das hat Scholz und sein Team haben
das versäumt und das ist glaube ich ein
Fehler wo auch Schaden entstanden ist
vor allem bei den Alliierten die sowas
möglicherweise erwarten die USA z.B sind
wesentlich besser durch größere
Erfahrung einfach sich für bestimmte
Szenarien vorzubereiten dass auch
unauffällig zu machen ohne dass du damit
wie gesagt Entscheidungen vorweg nimmst
aber die prüfen in jedem Tag sozusagen
neu was könnte die nächste Stufe sein
ich bin mir auch sicher dass in den USA
sehr intensiv und auch sozusagen in der
Sache schon darüber oder mit dem
Gedanken gespielt wird was wäre
eigentlich bei einer
kampfjet-entscheidung was hätte das für
Konsequenzen wie kann man das technisch
lösen und ich glaube da sind wir immer
ein Stück hinterher bei der Frage bei
der dann stelle ich die Frage zurück sie
haben den Blick jetzt auf die
Bundesregierung auf Urlaub Scholz
gelenkt das ist ein Aspekt auf den wir
gucken müssen also schlage ich vor
machen wir das zuerst Mittwoch im
Deutschen Bundestag seine Worte
es gibt in diesem Land viele Bürgern und
Bürger die sich Sorgen machen auch
angesichts einer solchen Entscheidung
und angesichts der Dimensionen die diese
Waffe mit sich bringt und deshalb möchte
ich diesen Bürgern und Bürgern hier und
an dieser Stelle sagen vertrauen Sie mir
vertrauen Sie der Bundesregierung wir
werden weiter weil wir international
abgestimmt Handeln sicherstellen dass
diese Unterstützung möglich ist ohne
dass die Risiken für unser Land darüber
in eine falsche Richtung wachsen das ist
warum wir das so tun und so werden wir
es auch weitermachen das ist jemand der
als zöderer Zögerer Zauderer Schweiger
wochenlang tätowiert wurde der jetzt ein
sehr staatsmanagement Auftritt hat
verdient er das Vertrauen und dass er
bittet ich glaube er müsste nicht erst
nach so einer Entscheidung um das
Vertrauen bitten ich glaube es gibt ja
in Deutschland einfach egal wie die
Umfragen dann mal bei 35 bei 45% gegen
Waffen liefern gegen schwere Panzer
Erzähler liegen es gibt eine ganze Reihe
von Leuten die sich Sorgen machen in dem
Land das sind aber
meines Erachtens nicht nicht Putin
Trolle oder Leute die zynisch sind
böswig der Ukraine nicht helfen wollen
die sondern die Sorgen um die sich ja
Deutschland Europas etc haben und die
direkt anzusprechen mit denen diese
Sorge zu nehmen anstatt am Ende nach
einer Entscheidung sozusagen bitte
vertrauen Sie mir wir machen das schon
und jetzt haben wir ein paar Wochen
wieder werden sie irgendwie Gerüchte
hören und am Ende werde ich Ihnen sagen
wie es gelaufen ist ich glaube es wird
zwar viel nach diplomatiken Moskau
gerufen aber es müsste vielleicht noch
ein bisschen mehr die blumentieren nach
innen geben vielleicht müsste er stolz
auch mal in Schwerin oder ein Erfurt
oder so auftreten damit man zwar
ausgepfiffen aber mit den Leuten ins
Gespräch zu gehen Herr schwebt ähm
entschuldigt bei der Raffinerie PC-Karte
wurde da teilweise niedergebrüllt aber
am Ende haben Leute auch gesagt Respekt
dass er hier war dass wir uns geredet
hat und uns versucht hat das zu erkennen
ich glaube auch wenn man in voller
Kenntnis der Dinge die da abgewogen
werden
ist dann hat man auch das Vertrauen also
was lässt Herrn Scholz zögern was
spricht dafür was er also dies die
einfach die die Menschen mitzunehmen in
diesen Abwägungsprozess das wäre
wirklich etwas
dann hat er Vertrauen verdient dann
bekommt er es auch aber er tut es nicht
und er tut es eben einen wiederholtes
mal nicht und deshalb ist es dann sowohl
Fall hinterher zu sagen bitte vertrauen
Sie mir jetzt schreibe ich auch gesagt
haben was ist eigentlich das Ziel das
die Bundesregierung der besten verfolgt
ein Gedanke noch also von Wladimir Putin
sind wir es gewohnt dass er täuscht dass
er lügt
was erwartet man von einer demokratisch
gewählten Regierungen in einer
Kriegssituation wie offen muss sie wie
offen kann sie eigentlich sagen was sie
gerade tut denkt machen will ja ich fast
diese das was die Kollegen gesagt haben
immer sozusagen etwas vorzubereiten
heißt ja dass man weiß was man tun wird
und ich glaube das ist nicht unbedingt
der Fall sondern das ist eben ein
konditioniertes tun und Scholz hat es ja
anders mitmachen der Amerikaner geknüpft
und es war nicht so dass er vor drei
Monaten schon wusste wir wollen die
Panzer liefern und wir wollen dass die
Amerikaner mitmachen und wir wissen dass
sie mitmachen werden das ist glaube ich
wirklich was was ich in dem Prozess
ergibt und insofern habe ich da also ich
will auf keinen Fall seine kommunikative
Performance verteidigen die ist glaube
ich schwierig die bringt auch noch ganz
andere Schwierigkeiten mit sich das ist
ja keine Stilfrage sondern da das
Problem dieser Kommunikation ist ja dass
da Interpretationen dran geknüpft werden
genau die Scholz will keine Panzer
liefern Scholz glaubt gar nicht gesagt
hatte alles nicht gesagt hat aber das
gibt natürlich Raum für solche
Interpretationen und deswegen ist es am
Ende auch nicht egal er selbst würde
immer sagen lass die alle reden ich bin
der Kanzlerin am Ende entscheide ich ich
glaube so ist es nicht trotzdem habe ich
Verständnis dafür dass das ein Prozess
ist indem man zwischen diesen Polen
auslotet und indem man eben unter
Umständen nicht schon lange vorher weiß
was man dann auch vorbereiten muss dazu
kommt glaube ich was Matthias Gebauer
gesagt hat man kann ja nicht etwas
vorbereiten und hinterher sagen ach nee
jetzt machen wir es doch nicht ich
glaube das wäre schwierig vielleicht
haben wir da nicht die Routine wie die
Amerikaner das auf eine etwas
verborgenere Art zu machen ich glaube
aber das wäre wer bei uns kaum möglich
da ist jetzt ein bisschen hart gesagt
aber noch so ein bisschen im
Kindergarten fast im Gegensatz zu den
Amerikanern die natürlich sowas
dauerhaft jeden Tag eigentlich mehr oder
weniger machen also dem Präsidenten
werden jeden Tag Optionen auf dem Tisch
gelegt bestimmte Richtung das fehlt
glaube ich bei uns so ein bisschen und
dafür fehlt möglicherweise auch
tatsächlich ein also ein eigenes Gremium
in der Bundesregierung glaube ich die
sich mit so welchen Fragen eben auch auf
einer anderen Ebene der Vertraulichkeit
unterhalten wo dann auch Partei
Interessen nicht so eine große Rolle
spielen also von daher wenn man ein
bisschen nach vorne guckt glaube ich
können wir da viel lernen dass uns ein
bisschen so ein strategischer Muskel oft
auch fehlt der abseits der Tagespolitik
so welche Fragen behandelt und dann eben
den Regierenden auch Optionen vorliegt
das sind wie gesagt Optionen über die
dann die Politik am Ende entscheidet
ich wollte nur noch einmal zu dem
Auftritt von Bundestag und am Abend im
ZDF am vergangenen Mittwoch was sagen
weil das ist so ein kommunikationsthema
es wird ja seitdem berichtet herr Scholz
hätte den Lieferung von Kampfjets
ausgeschlossen wenn man sich aber genau
seine Antworten anhört dann tut ihr das
nicht er wird gefragt wenn sie Kampfjet
liefern dann sagt er nein wir haben ja
von Anfang an gesagt dass wir keine
Flugverbotszone in der Ukraine
einrichten das ist aber nicht das
Gleiche eine Flugverbotszone würde durch
NATO-Truppen westliche Truppen
durchgesetzt hier geht's aber darum Jets
in die Ukraine für Ukraine zu liefern
und das wäre so als hätte man Herrn
Scholz vor zwei Wochen gefragt werden
sie Leoparden in die Ukraine liefern er
hätte gesagt nein deutsche Soldaten
werden keine Leoparden in die Ukraine
fahren und er korrigiert das nicht sein
Speicher korrigiert das nicht das läuft
weiter und in drei vier Wochen fragen
sich die Leute wenn die Diskussion die
Kampfjets wieder anfängt wieso der
Scheiß hat das doch ausgeschlossen wobei
ich den Eindruck hatte dass er das mehr
ausgeschlossen hat als die Panzer also
ja ja
aber das was er gesagt hat der kann ja
reden wenn er will ein User bei Twitter
warum hat der Bundeskanzler keine
Strategie in Punkte Ukraine das ist der
Eindruck der in der Frage formuliert ist
stimmt der Eindruck
ich glaube
ja und nein
er hatte eine Strategie was
Friedensverhandlungen angeht da ist er
sehr sehr klar
indem er immer wieder sagt es wird nicht
ohne die Ukraine über die Ukraine
entschieden und verhandelt
so viel Klarheit hat nicht jeder in
diesem Punkt da gibt es schon auch die
Ansichten dass zwischen NATO und
Russland verhandelt werden soll und da
finde ich ihn sehr eindeutig
ansonsten ist es das was Frau Hildebrand
gesagt hat dass dieses nicht definierte
Ziel ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man
wirklich keine Ziel definieren kann wie
sollte es also diese Rumeierei darf
nicht der darf den Krieg nicht gewinnen
darf ihn nicht verlieren dass das
zeugt ja davon dass er eigentlich nicht
ganz genau weiß wie diese Ukraine nach
diesem Krieg aussehen soll das wissen
wir natürlich alle nicht nicht weil bis
dahin ein langer Weg ist aber wir haben
vielleicht eine
eine Zielvorstellung wohin es gehen
müsste rein völkerrechtlich müsste es
dahin gehen dass die Grenzen von 1991
wieder eingehalten werden und dieses
Ziel warum wir das nicht definiert dafür
hat er natürlich Gründe aber es wäre
doch schön sie mal auch seine Mund zu
hören war er möchte sich oder man
mutmaße kann ich ja nur sagen er möchte
sich vielleicht ein Fensterchen offen
lassen für Friedensverhandlungen das ist
da eine Verhandlungsmasse gibt aber das
müsste selber sagen ich glaube der
Zusammenhang oder die Schwierigkeit ist
da dass die es ist nicht so dass eine
sind die Ziele und das andere sind die
Waffenlieferungen sondern die Waffen die
von uns sind natürlich implizit auch
immer eine Aussage darüber was halte ich
eigentlich im Moment für möglich in
diesem Krieg und das hat sich ja sehr
verändert also wir erinnern uns an die
Experten die am Anfang gesagt haben nach
drei Tagen ist da Schluss und Russland
hat gewonnen und genau das was Sie
beschreiben ist glaube ich genau der
Punkt es macht sich ja zum Beispiel fest
an der Krim die eine Rolle gespielt hat
als es jetzt um diese Panzerlieferungen
ging weil man hörte immer wieder und das
das ist dann manchmal so man hört dann
Dinge man weiß es nicht genau weil es
wird nicht erklärt dass auch ein Grund
für das Zögern war dass man nicht wollte
dass die Ukraine diese Panzer nutzt um
auf die Krim zu fahren darüber gibt es
offensichtlich unterschiedliche
Einschätzungen auch ob das ob das
wünschenswert ist ob das überhaupt
hinnehmbar ist ob das etwas ist was
passieren darf wenn man sich an das hält
was völkerrechtlich beschlossen ist
gehört es natürlich der Ukraine trotzdem
sind da möglicherweise Folgen dran
gekoppelt Reaktion von Russland die man
dann einkalkulieren und da fängt es eben
schon an dann sehr die Fuß zu werden
wenn man sich drüber was für eine
Ukraine wird ein Einschub der
renommierte demokratische
Verteidigungspolitiker Adam Smith hat im
Interview der Frankfurter Allgemeinen
gesagt sein Erkenntnis nach würden die
Leoparden nicht für die Creme eingesetzt
das nur als als Einschub
ich würde aber gerne noch mal aufgreifen
was sie gerade gesagt haben mit meinen
Worten
man kann ein Fernziel haben aber welche
Mittel geeignet sind kann sich von Tag
zu Tag verändern heißt jetzt in meinen
Worten die Entscheidung Leoparden zu
schicken kann heute ganz anders bewertet
und eingeordnet werden als vor zwei oder
vor drei oder vier Monaten jetzt auch
mit Blick auf die Kampf der Diskussion
Herr Gebauer ist das so braucht jedes
Instrument den richtigen Zeitpunkt hat
das Abwarten mit Entscheidungen auch
damit zu tun dass Dinge heute vielleicht
falsch wären und morgen richtig sein
können ich glaube das Problem ist dass
die Entscheidung immer etwas verzögert
getroffen werden weil der richtige
Prozess hin zu der Entscheidung beginnt
erst wenn man die militärische
Notwendigkeit sieht und dann geht ein
Diskussionsprozess in der Politik gehen
zwei drei Monate und diese Zeit ist
eigentlich zu lang ich denke mal die
Notwendigkeit von Panzern
oder von moderneren Panzern für die
Ukraine hat man ende letzten Jahre
spätestens im November Dezember
definiert oder plötzlich waren sich alle
einig und dann hat man aber noch
anderthalb Monate gebraucht bis zur
Entscheidung und da glaube ich brauchen
wir einen Lernprozess das muss schneller
gehen auch in der internationalen
Abstimmung und deswegen noch mal das was
ich vorher gesagt habe wenn man es schon
mal ein bisschen vorbereitet hätte zum
Beispiel einfach mit den Polen schon mal
geredet etwas könntet ihr euch
vorstellen was habt ihr wie könnten wir
das Kombinieren dann hätte man jetzt
nicht diese lange Verzögerung okay ich
fass mit Blick auf die Bundesregierung
auf Olaf Scholz zusammen also die
Vermutung von Frau Adler geäußert ist es
gibt eine Strategie und ein Ziel was
Friedensverhandlungen angeht was fernere
Dinge angeht aber aus dem Tag heraus aus
der Situation heraus immer ein Abwägen
ein prüfen dass wir erhebauer sagt sehr
lange dauert weil nicht Optionen fertig
in der Schublade liegen wollte noch mal
eine Sache allerdings zu dem Thema
Kommunikation sich erklären ich glaube
dass Olaf scheut sich ja auch einmal
ziemlich am Anfang in einem Spiegel
Interview da hat er ja ein bisschen die
Klappen aufgemacht also das war dieses
Spiegelcover haben sie Angst herr Scholz
und da berichtet er ja da auch zum
ersten Mal relativ ausführlich sagt
viele richtige Sachen es gibt keinen
Lehrbuch für den Krieg das die
militärische Lage verändert sich und
erwähnt eben die Angst vor dem Atomkrieg
das ist um die Welt gegangen Olaf Scholz
fürchtet sich vor einem Atomkrieg und
dafür hat er auch wahnsinnig viel
schälte bekommen weil das aus Sicht der
Alliierten
falsches Messaging war dass man
zurückgeht und sagt wir haben Angst vor
Putin dass dieses Thema wird aufgebracht
wird und ich glaube daraus hat er ein
bisschen gelernt oder zumindest aus
seiner sich gelernt eben nicht mehr so
reingucken zu lassen auch in sein in die
Hintergründe und das ist natürlich
tragisch weil ich glaube dass solche
Erklärungen Kommunikation hat sich ja
immer so an als ob es sozusagen per geht
das ein gut aussehen zu lassen ich finde
bei Olaf Scholz und gerade bei diesen
wirklich fundamental wichtigen
Entscheidungen geht es in der Demokratie
nicht darum dass er gut aussieht sondern
er muss das was er tut erklären und das
macht er nicht gut danke ich hatte
vorhin die Frage in den Raum gestellt
von unseren Userinnen und User wie
werden die Russen reagieren das was sie
jetzt beschrieben haben die Angst ich
glaube jeder am Tisch würde lügen wenn
er oder sie völlig frei von der
Überlegung wäre wohin das führen kann
als Journalistin Nationalist darf man
das sagen als Politiker muss man sich
das vielleicht genauer überlegen Frau
Adler sie haben ja auch aus Moskau
berichtet im früheren Zeiten ich zitiere
mal Reaktionen Kreml Sprecher pestov
sagt diese Panzer werden brennen wie
andere auch der Botschafter in Berlin
der sagt das ist extrem gefährlich es
gibt Stimmen von Propagandisten im Kreml
die sprechen von der Zerstörung Berlins
als nächsten Schritt
Blick auf Russland und Putin welche
Reaktion ist jetzt zu erwarten also
diese Reaktion haben ja gezeigt dass sie
empfindlich getroffen sind durch diese
Entscheidung und ich würde mal vermuten
dass es nicht die Entscheidung war
Kampfpanzer zu schicken sondern dass es
die Entscheidung war dass sich die
Amerikaner tatsächlich von den Europäern
derartig noch mal zusätzlich in die
Pflichten nehmen lassen und das was
jetzt sich abzeichnet ist das auf
russischer Seite so viele Menschen die
irgendwie möglich rekrutiert werden das
ist sichtbar also die Rekrutierungen
laufen in den Strafkolonien von
pregorien also dieser sogenannten Wagner
Söldnertruppe sie laufen sowieso obwohl
sie noch nicht erklärt worden sind in
einer weiteren mobil machen die
angeblich größer ausfallen soll als die
erste mit 500.000 Mann nicht mehr
300.000 wie im September
und wenn man sieht dass ich Putin
vornehmlich in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen abbilden lassen hat vor in
Rüstungsbetrieben und da immer
Zahlenspielchen auch gemacht hat also
Russland stellt so viele Raketen her wie
der Rest der Welt und wir werden
überlegen ob wir die rüstungsarbeiter
verschonen vom Wehrdienst vom
Kriegsdienst sagt er natürlich nicht
dann sind das alles Anzeichen dafür dass
Russland gewählt ist alles reinzuwerfen
und ich würde gerne noch einen Gedanken
loswerden wollen in Bezug auf die
Kampfjets die Entscheidung für diese
Waffe wäre auch finde ich zu treffen vor
dem Hintergrund
wie hat die Ukraine agiert bis jetzt
welche Rolle haben Kampfjets bis jetzt
gespielt und sie haben an einer Stelle
oder ein zwei Stellen sogar meine
ziemlich entscheidende Rolle gespielt
als sie mich die Ukraine
Stützpunkte milit Stützpunkte auf der
Krim angegriffen haben wo Kampfjets
gestanden haben das heißt also das kann
durchaus Sinn machen diese Kampfjets
auch einzusetzen wenn damit die
Befreiung des eigenen Territoriums
gemeint ist wenn damit gemeint ist dass
Angriffe auf russisches Territorium
geflogen werden sollen muss man sich das
auch im Einzelnen angucken ich glaube
dass man das zum heutigen Zeitpunkt
nicht völlig ausschließen kann
das war schon der Bogen zu den Jets
sprechen wir auch gleich drüber wir
kamen von den Beobachtungen die Frau
Adler gemacht hat was die russischen
Reaktionen angeht das leitet sich für
Sie daraus ab mich hat neulich eine Dame
um die 50 was gefragt was ich irgendwie
entwaffen empfand die die sagte zu mir
und ich weiß sozusagen eine Frau die
sich interessiert für die Polizei
Entwicklung in der Ukraine aber jetzt
keine Politikerin ist keine Experte und
die sagte in Russland leben doch viel
mehr Menschen als in der Ukraine was
passiert denn eigentlich wenn die immer
und immer und immer weiter einfach neue
Menschen an die Front werfen wie sollen
die Ukraine das dann überhaupt
zurückwerfen also wenn Putin ganz
reingeht und ich wusste nicht wirklich
was ich darauf antworten sollte da würde
ich gerne drauf antworten weil mir hat
wiederum eine Ukraine nicht irgendeine
sondern eine
Vizepräsidentin geantwortet auf die
Frage dass die menschlichen Ressourcen
wenn man das mal so bezeichnen darf
natürlich in einem Missverhältnis stehen
auf der einen Seite 40 Millionen auf der
anderen Seite 140 Millionen und da sagte
sie es kommt nicht auf die Quantität der
Kämpfer an sondern auf die Qualität sie
sind also sehr zuversichtlich ich gebe
es nur wieder wollten sie noch
anschließen ja ich glaube das muss man
schon erklären aber das sind halt auch
so Sachen die Fragen sich Menschen diese
Größenverhältnisse wie kann man das
erklären und wie weit soll das
weitergehen und wie viele Leute werden
dann noch sterben müssen
Sie uns die Runde zu den Kampfjets
drehen Frau Adler hat sie noch mal
eröffnet er Gebauer also niemand an
diesem Tisch ist Flugzeug Experte aber
in der Vorbereitung habe ich gelesen
dass die Ukraine zwar über eine Reihe
russischer Kampfflugzeuge mit 29 von der
Bauart her verfügt dass sie auch
unterstützt worden ist mit Munition und
Ersatzteilen aus verschiedenen
europäischen Ländern dass das aber
langsam zu Ende gehe und ist deshalb
möglicherweise gar nicht mehr möglich
sein mit diesen
zu fliegen und das wird als Argument
dafür genannt dass der besten da jetzt
unterstützen müsse was ist ihr Blick auf
dieses Thema also die Ukraine verfügt ja
vom Anfang des Krieges über tatsächlich
eine kleine mit 29 Flotte die aber immer
wieder eingesetzt wurde die ist deutlich
von der Schlagkraft her verstärkt worden
dadurch dass die Ukrainer zusammen mit
den Amerikanern es geschafft haben da
moderne Lenkflugkörper dran zu also dran
zu schrauben hört sich jetzt etwas
simpel an
gleichwohl ich wollte noch mal auf das
eingehen was Frau Adler gesagt und das
ist glaube ich ganz entscheidend man
muss sich ja fragen wofür sollten
Kampfjets eigentlich dienen wenn bevor
wir uns überlegen ob wir sie liefern und
die Zerstörung von russischen Basen auf
russischen Gebiet wäre natürlich ein
großer Schlag gegen die Russen aber
diese Schläge würden niemals also
zumindest aus meiner Sicht niemals mit
Kampfjets durchgeführt weil du auf
russisches Gebiet bekommst gar nicht
durch die Luft Abwehr von den Russen und
die ist tatsächlich ziemlich effektiv
und das ist ihre militärische
Einschätzung da sozusagen durchzukommen
dann müsstest du eigentlich ein full
flash war mit Russland anfangen müssen
zuerst die Luftabwehr ausschalten das
wird schon sehr schwierig und im Krieg
über der Ukraine das ist zwar brutal das
sozusagen aber spielen Kampfjets im
Moment keine große Rolle und würden auch
bei der Verteidigung gegen Drohnen zum
Beispiel du kannst mit einem Kampfjet
kannst du eigentlich nicht gegen Drohnen
Vorgehen das heißt wenn du gegen die
Bedrohung aus der Luft die im Moment wie
gesagt hauptsächlich Drohnen relativ
einfache Raketen wenn du darauf
reagieren willst und die Ukraine besser
schützen willst musst du noch mehr
Luftverteidigung liefern aber keine
Kampfjets deswegen sehe ich abseits
davon dass es ein interessantes Thema
ist und natürlich politisch sehr
umstritten aber militärisch sehe ich im
Moment das Fenster für die Kampfjets gar
nicht ich meine ich glaube das politisch
heikle ist ja die Außenministerin hat ja
einen spektakulären Satz gesagt diese
Woche nämlich wir sind im Krieg gegen
Russland ist ein glaube ich ziemlich
fataler und falscher Satz und genau das
ist ja von Anfang an das Bedürfnis und
die Linie das ist die Linie die wirklich
keiner verleugnet dass die NATO nicht
involviert werden will in den Krieg und
die Ukraine möchte die NATO involvieren
und das ist natürlich ein grundlegender
Unterschied und wenn ich das richtig
verstehe ich bin keine waffenexpertin
aber dann ist ja das besonders heikle an
dieser nächsten Stufe Kampfjets dass
diese diese also dieses Thema der
absichtlichen oder versehentlichen
Involvierung in der Luft dann doch
erheblich schneller passieren kann jetzt
sage ich Ihnen mal was mir durch den
Kopf geht also ich habe großen Respekt
vor dem Völkerrecht ja und ich lese und
verstehe wenn ich Panzer schicke ohne
Leute drin ist das keine
Kriegsbeteiligung das ist offenbar eine
internationale rechtliche Vereinbarung
ich erlebe auf der anderen Seite das
Wladimir Putin ja nichts auf das
Völkerrecht gibt und in den letzten
Monaten alles nach Lust und Laune getan
hat und nicht nach den Regeln des
Völkerrechts also insofern warum halten
wir den Glauben aufrecht das ist keine
Beteiligung am Krieg ist wenn jetzt
deutsche Panzer
wir können doch nicht sagen nur weil
Putin sich nicht ans Völkerrecht hält
tun wir das auch nicht also wenn wir das
nicht mehr ernst nehmen diese
Unterscheidung dann wird es schwierig
glaube ich ja aber kann es für seine
Reaktion am Ende eine Rolle spielen das
glaube ich immer überhaupt nicht dann
erhält sich nicht daran und er wird es
also ich glaube diese Definition ob das
jetzt völkerrechtsgemäß ist oder nicht
interessiert ihn überhaupt nicht denn
dann hätte er z.B diesen Krieg nicht
angefangen also dass das und die Krimi
nicht besetzt und und überhaupt also
das ist nicht nur sagen also wenn wir
uns nur an diesem Argument festhalten
dass ich absolut legitim und aus unserer
Sicht für notwendig halte heißt das ja
nicht dass auf der anderen Seite
Wladimir Putin auch seine Entscheidungen
davon abhängig machen dass wir sozusagen
uns gegenüber machen und da finde ich
ist es nicht ganz unwichtig wenn wir
daraus ableiten dann der Putin guckt ins
Völkerrecht und sagt ach die sind nicht
beteiligt dann stimme ich total zu das
und ich finde eben auch uns gegen heißt
eben auch unsere Soldaten da
reinschicken also das ist ich glaube
dass das ist schon noch mal so eine so
derartig neue Kategorie mit einmal eine
Kriegsbeteiligung zu haben also mit
eigenen Truppen das ist nun wirklich da
gemüsste man auch sehr lange drüber
diskutieren finde ich unserem Gästebuch
was wären die konkreten Konsequenzen
wenn Deutschland aus russischer Sicht
Kriegspartei wäre
wahrscheinlich hätte es gar keine
Konsequenz aus meiner Sicht im Moment
weil also wir haben das ja am Anfang der
Kriegsphase ist das glaube ich sehr
intensiv auch im Kanzleramt und auch bei
den Amerikanern diskutiert worden diese
was wäre wenn Frage
sieht er uns nun als Kriegspartei könnte
er damit auch Angriffe zum Beispiel
gegen Deutschland es müssen ja nicht
immer gleich militärische Angriffe sein
es können ja auch selber Angriffe seines
können Sabotage Akte sein wir haben ja
merkwürdige Sabotage gesehen Nord Stream
2 bis heute weiß niemand wer es war wir
haben andere Sabotage gesehen also es
können auch kleine Nadelstiche sein aber
diese Abwägung nehme ich überhaupt nicht
mehr wahr die ist auch vor dieser
panzerfrage gespielt stand gar nicht
mehr so im Vordergrund weil aus
putinsicht ist der Westen am Krieg
beteiligt durch die Waffenlieferung und
gleichwohl geht er nicht den Schritt den
Westen direkt zu attackieren und ich
glaube deswegen spielt diese was wäre
wenn Frage nicht mehr
Frage das ist bei dem angesprochen den
Atomthema weil das ist ja sozusagen auch
ein gewisser Widerspruch auf der einen
Seite sagt Olaf Scholz nicht das Putin
mit einem Atomkrieg gedroht hat und
bestreitet dass er Angst hat auf der
anderen Seite liegt natürlich die
Involvierung der USA die die innere
Logik davon liegt natürlich genau darin
dass man ein Risiko für Deutschland
minimieren will wissen dass wir keine
eigenen Atomwaffen haben wissen dass wir
da auf Amerikaner angewiesen sind und in
der Absicht ein abschreckungsargument
gegenüber Russland aufrecht zu erhalten
also da ist es auch so ein bisschen eine
diffuse Lage und da spielen diese
Abwägung natürlich nach wie vor sehr
wohl eine Rolle und auch wenn man sich
darauf einigt dass man viele Experten
sagen ja es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich
man möchte aber einfach nicht drauf
ankommen lassen ich glaube die Frage
spielt er in politischen Rolle als für
Putin Putin sieht ja auch die Umfragen
die wir hier in Deutschland haben wer
hat Zweifel an den Waffenlieferung und
wenn man in der Lage ist dieses
Potenzial von besorgten Menschen von etc
auszunutzen und zu sagen das ist aber
nicht mehr völkerrechtswidrige Völk
konform oder dadurch wird mein
Kriegspartei dann kann ja dieser Zweifel
auch wachsen und das könnte dann eben
auch wieder die Waffenlieferung an sich
gefährden und Äpfel Putin scheint es
auch ohne Kriegs Militär zu sein doch
nicht sinnvoll zu sein ein Krieg den er
verliert durch einen zweiten Krieg
sozusagen noch schwieriger zu machen
weitere Fronten zu eröffnen also dass er
sozusagen wenn er in der Ukraine solche
Schwierigkeiten hat jetzt die NATO damit
reinziehen sollte das kann ich mir die
tierisch zumindest nicht helfen da bin
ich mir nicht so sicher wenn man das
sieht also Stichwort zweite Front dass
es Überlegung gibt doch noch mal von
Belarus aus eine früher als Offensive
z.B die NATO sondern auch aber also auch
diese frontia sowieso schon viel zu
lange ist und kommen irgendwie zu
bewältigen ist und wir haben das ja ganz
zu Anfang dieser Invasion gemerkt oder
gesehen das ist dieser Angriff von drei
Seiten war einfach zu viel war nicht zu
händeln war schlecht ausgeführt und so
weiter und das jetzt noch mal zu machen
ist nicht vom Tisch erstaunlicherweise
ja also ich mein Kiew in die
sangbewegung zu nehmen davon hatte ich
auch gehört aber dass er jetzt sagen
würde wir warten auf dem Moment wo der
Westen wo die NATO ein Fehler macht und
dann können wir endlich das Baltikum
angreifen also dass das glaube ich das
ist gar nicht in seinem Sinne sie haben
wie gesagt dann waren ganz wichtiger
Punkt nochmal diese Sicht und die ist
aus der westlichen Strategie glaube ich
eine ganz entscheidende wie sieht Putin
die Ukraine Unterstützer und wir haben
ja sehr viel darüber diskutiert Olaf
Scholz will die USA dazu haben als
Absicherung als Risikostreuung das ist
glaube ich alles richtig aber was nicht
so sehr beachtet wird bei dieser
Diskussion ist das Scholz ja auch sehr
stark versucht hat andere europäische
Partner die bisher sehr sehr leise sind
zum Beispiel interessant war letzte
Woche dass er Meloni mit dazu genommen
hat zu der Runde unter den G7 startchefs
liegt Italien spielt bisher bei den
Waffen die haben fast überhaupt keine
Rolle steht dem innerhalb der EU und
auch innerhalb der Natur aus das
kritisch gegenüber und da versucht
Scholz sozusagen auch europäische
Partner die bisher noch ein bisschen
wackeln
es gibt ja auch an der Ostflanke mit
Ungarn zum Beispiel Land was absolut
wackelt und völlig Unentschieden ist
oder vielleicht sogar möglicherweise
mehr Richtung Russland tendiert und das
versucht er alles zusammenzubinden da
haben wir uns glaube ich manchmal ein
bisschen zu sehr auf die USA fokussiert
es geht auch sehr darum die Front also
die Front hört sich sehr hart an aber
die Unterstützer Linie in Europa auch
zusammenzuhalten ja ich komme zum Adler
ich ich komme zu einer Frage die man am
Schluss auf jeden Fall einmal stellen
muss ich versuche mal zusammenzufassen
wir haben erläutert warum diese Panzer
jetzt zwangsläufig waren welche
Bedeutung sie haben wie die deutsche
Abwägung zwischen rational würde Putin
keinen weiteren Krieg suchen und
irrational muss man sich trotzdem
absichern und überlegen welchen Schutz
die Amerikaner bieten wie man ein
Bündnis zusammenhält wir haben darüber
gesprochen dass die Kampfjets als
Debatte laufen unterschiedlich sinnvoll
eingeschätzt werden aber die
Entscheidung darüber wird kommen und
trotzdem Hilde kann man die Sendung
nicht schließen ohne die Frage wie gibt
es denn jetzt trotz allem einen Weg zu
Waffenstillstand zu Verhandlungen wie
weit ist das weg und wo lang führt
dieser Weg also nach allem was man hört
wenn man mit Leuten spricht die sich
damit beschäftigen dann sagen die
eigentlich alle ziemlich weit weg weil
im Moment einfach dieser Punkt nach wie
vor nicht erreicht ist wo eine Partei so
geschwächt ist dass sie sich nicht einen
Vorteil davon verspricht das vorzusetzen
und deswegen kann man das eben auch
glaube ich so schwer
vorhersagen wann das sein wird weil
dieser Moment der muss der muss
eintreten und der ist offensichtlich
noch nicht so sehr in sich außer
Sichtweite gibt's da andere
Einschätzungen
und das passiert was unvorhergesehen ist
das kann man auch nicht ausschließen was
gerade passiert welche Diskussionen wir
haben
nichtsdestotrotz
laufen die Bemühungen hoffentlich im
Hintergrund
auch wenn wir davon nichts hören ich
hoffe das sehr dass da Anstrengungen
unternommen werden denn es muss
irgendwann an irgendeiner Stelle muss
irgendetwas begonnen werden zu
verhandeln ich denke da zum Beispiel an
den datenprozess auf dem Balkan Boss
sind die Jahren aber zumindest wurde mal
irgendwann begonnen als auch kein Mensch
von Frieden jemals irgendwie nur zu
träumen wagte ich glaube derzeit ist es
sehr schwierig gerade auch weil Putin ja
so viel investiert hat in diesen Krieg
und es ist ja auch nicht vorstellbar
dass bei friedensverhandlung direkt oder
ohne
auch ein sozusagen ja eine Verurteilung
von Kriegsverbrechern beispielsweise
eine Rückkehr zu einem Status Quote
möglich wäre in dem wieder einfach Gas
durch Nord Stream läuft oder so also ich
gerade gerade habe ich das Gefühl ist
sozusagen das noch nicht ausgereizt
leider und weiter weggerückt diese Woche
ich sehe in diesem Jahr keinen Frieden
kommen
das Bittere ist aus meiner Sicht das nur
Putin selber diese Entscheidung treffen
kann in jedem normalen Kriegsszenario
würde ich immer sagen dass er schon
lange kurz davor sein müsste wie sie
richtig gesagt haben die hohen Verluste
vor allem der hohe Blutzoll den er den
er zahlen muss und der ja auch vor der
russischen Öffentlichkeit nicht mehr
geheim zu halten sind diese
Satellitenbilder zum Beispiel von diesen
das sind ja wirklich fast Massengräber
die da ausgehoben werden von Soldaten
die kaum ausgebildet sind und dann da
ins Feuer geschickt werden das wird
natürlich irgendwann seine Wirkung haben
aber wir sehen die Wirkung bisher noch
nicht und ich glaube das ja gestern auch
noch mal im Interview gesagt er wird
weiter haben mit Putin telefonieren das
ist auch richtig ich glaube es ist so
oder so richtig das war ja schon immer
die Theorie von Scholz dass Putin so
isoliert ist in seinem eigenen in seinem
eigenen Kreis von Leuten die ihn
möglicherweise mit der Realität nicht
mehr konfrontieren das ist so oder so
gut ist mit ihm zu sprechen und ihm
zumindestens einmal noch mal den
westlichen Blick zu zeigen aber bisher
nach all dem was wir gehört haben war
bei diesen Gesprächen nicht ein Hauch
von Verhandlungsbereitschaft zu erkennen
und die sind wirklich jedem
sprichwörtlichen Streichholz
hinterhergelaufen und haben das versucht
da noch mal anzuknüpfen bedanke mich für
diese Einschätzung stelle sie jetzt vor
die Entscheidung wenn sie in der ARD
weiter dabei sind folgt das Europa
Magazin unter anderem mit einem
Interview mit dem Leiter der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz Christoph Heusgen
und wenn Sie hier da bleibt dabei
bleiben wollen im Netz bei Phoenix bei
WDR 5 dann jetzt Presseclub nachgefragt
danke tschüss und lassen Sie es gut
gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Netz im Radio bei WDR 5
und im Fernsehen bei Phoenix und ich
beginne mal in Berlin bei Christoph
bovara guten Tag ja schönen guten Tag
vielen Dank dass Sie mich in die Sendung
genommen haben ich hatte dieser Tage
auch Fokus online gelesen dass alles was
die USA an Unterstützung an die Ukraine
gibt entweder Kredite sind oder bei den
Waffen das ist nicht da um verliesungen
handelt und auf diesen Punkt wird mir
doch in den Medien viel zu wenig
hingewiesen weil ich hier doch auch
gewisse Interessen oder Interessen will
der USA Wirtschaft
das wollte ich einfach mal ein ja danke
habe ich auch in der Diskussion im Netz
gelesen so die Frage ist das Geschenk
oder was ist das eigentlich für eine
vertragliche Beziehung weiß das jemand
in der Runde
also ich weiß es zum Teil aber es sind
keine sind keine Kredite sondern die USA
also jetzt zum Beispiel im Fall der der
Abrams Panzer das ist zwar so ein
bisschen kurios also die sind die werden
ja nicht aus Armee Beständen abgegeben
sondern sie werden tatsächlich neu
produziert vom Hersteller die Ukraine
bestellt sie beim Hersteller und die USA
die US-Regierung bezahlt aus einem
Ukraine hilfstopf die Rechnung
und ist das hergeschenktes Geld
Steuergeld oder ist das etwas was die
Ukraine irgendwann zumindest theoretisch
zurück bezahlen muss
also dieses Geld auch was dem eu-töpfe
sind keine das sind keine Schulden
sondern das sind Geschenke ja okay Herr
Bohrer danke ganz aufklären kann das
nicht aber die Interessen der
Rüstungsindustrie klar das steht außer
Zweifel da sind natürlich ganz andere
also die Rüstungsindustrie profitiert
natürlich von diesen Lieferungen auch
jetzt im deutschen Fall weil einfach
schlicht aus Bundeswehrbeständen
abgegeben wird und schon jetzt laufen
die Verhandlungen diese Panzer zu
ersetzen das ähnliche gilt für die
Panzerhaubitzen und grundsätzlich rüstet
sich natürlich ganz Europa vor allen
Dingen Osteuropa derzeit mit neuen
Waffen aus das heißt die
Rüstungsindustrie profitiert natürlich
von dieser Waffenhilfe direkt und
indirekt das ist keine Frage danke und
Gruß nach Berlin wir gehen weiter nach
Rastatt zu raulik guten Tag willkommen
ja guten Tag einen schönen Gruß in die
Runde
klingt für mich immer so als ob der
Scholz ganz alleine oder mit seinem
kanzleramtschefs bzw ganz wenigen Leuten
und es in der SPD bzw
Kabinett sich Gedanken über die
Lieferung von zum Beispiel Panzern in
die Ukraine macht gibt es vielleicht
irgendwie so eine Art ständigen Rad oder
starb aus Militär und Politiker oder wie
auch immer zusammengesetzt Europa oder
NATO der sich über Themen zur Strategie
beschäftigt
die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz wäre
für mich nicht die Antwort weil sie nur
im Jahr stattfindet könnte es vielleicht
ein Thema bzw Ergebnis nach dem Krieg
sein ja spannende Frage wer kennt die
Frau das was Matthias Gebauer gesagt hat
also es gibt einen Bundessicherheitsrat
der ist aber nicht dieses strategische
Gremium der beschäftigt sich in erster
Linie damit eben über Anträge auf
Waffenexporte zu entscheiden und das ist
genau das was Matthias Weber gesagt hat
eine etwas anderes wäre eine Monat
nationaler Sicherheitsrat in dem genau
solche Entscheidungen vorbereitet und
überlegt werden und solche Gedanken
angestellt werden
vielleicht wenn man das so ein bisschen
erklären will es gibt natürlich im
Bundeskanzleramt
also auch militärische Abteilungen wo
der Kanzler sich auch militärischen Rat
holen kann er hat sich auch jetzt vor
den Entscheidungen immer
wieder den Rat des generalinspektors der
Bundeswehr geholt aber was Sie
ansprechen das ist natürlich tatsächlich
noch so ein Vakuum nämlich ein und wir
hatten das ja in der Sendung jetzt auch
ein paar mal schon gesagt was
Deutschland ein bisschen fehlt ist ein
ständiges Gremium dass sich nicht anders
bezogen sondern dauerhaft mit so welchen
Krisenszenarien auseinandersetzen da
geht es eben nicht nur im zahlungsfall
um so ein Ukraine Konflikt sondern es
gibt ja auch andere
Krisensituationen auf der Welt die auch
lange laufen wo schon aus meiner Sicht
zumindestens sehr sinnvoll wäre dass
sich da ein Gremium mit Fachleuten mit
beschäftigt was erstmal
Stufe spannendes Thema und wir haben
gehört auch da ist eine Zeitenwende
nötig danke nach Rastatt und dann sind
wir in Bernau am Chiemsee bei Markus
Hofmann grüß Gott
ja hallo mein Name ist Hofmann Ich hätte
folgende Frage und zwar es wird hier
immer erzählt Russland wenn die All-In
gehen und was haben wir ab wie können
wir abwählen was weiß ich die Frage ist
folgende wenn Putin wirklich all ihn
hingehen würde
konventionell ich rede nicht mal von
atomar konventionell wie lange würde es
dauern bis eine Stadt wie hier
vollkommen verbrannte Erde ist
vollkommen
gelegt wie zum Beispiel Königsberg vor
ja also vor 70 80 Jahren wie lange würde
das dauern danke wie viel von seiner
Kraft setz Putin gerade ein und was
könnte erreichen wenn er alles einsetzen
würde also eine Sache die in der
Diskussion ist auch immer so ein
bisschen
ja nicht nicht ganz klar wird es es gibt
ja ganz viel zwischen Panzern und eine
Atomschlag dazwischen gibt's ja noch
ganz viele andere Möglichkeiten Flächen
Bombardements ist ja auch andere Waffen
es gibt B und C Waffen die die Russen
besitzen also es ist ja nicht so dass
direkte Atomkrieg ausbrechen muss ich
sehe bei der Strategie Putins noch keine
sozusagen völlige vernichtungsstrategie
aller Städte in in der Ukraine
gleichzeitig ist die ukrainische
Luftabwehr auch nicht schlecht besonders
durch Systeme wie ihres Tee das ja auch
die deutschen geliefert dass die
Deutschen geliefert haben das heißt die
Russen haben auch nicht die lufthoheiten
können dass da alles in Schutt und Asche
legen aber sag mal so ich glaube wenn
die Russen da ganz reingehen würden
müsste der Gebauer als Experte
vielleicht noch eine sekundieren dann
würde das nicht lange dauern okay lassen
wir stehen danke Herr Hofmann
anderer Aspekt glaube ich von Ralf
Langheim in Münster Tag nach Münster sie
sind dran ja
ich habe mal die Frage die putin ist ja
jetzt im letzten Jahr 70 geworden und
ist seit ziemlich genau im
Vierteljahrhundert an der Macht ich
frage mich ob da nicht andere Mal wollen
und ob die nicht sagen auf Atomkrieg
haben Sie keine Lust dann sind wir
selber weg wir wollen das Leben noch
genießen wie wir wie wahrscheinlich ist
das eigentlich das Putin beseitigt wird
also intern nicht von von außen sondern
[Musik]
von anderen Russen
ja jetzt sind wir wirklich in der
kremlastologie wer hat da tatsächlich
eine Chance so nah dran zu kommen
das wissen wir nicht wir wissen nicht
genau wer sich da in Stellung bringt das
verzichtbar ist dass
Rangeleien herrschen und und macht
keinen verherrschen innerhalb der
Armeeführung Verteidigungsminister schon
gut der neue generalstaatschef grassimov
dann pregorien und da heißt es das ist
das höre ich wiederum aus aus russischen
Quellen das ist gar nicht so sehr um die
Führung in dieser sogenannten
spezialoperation also in dem Krieg geht
sondern dass es da vor allem darum geht
wer hat den ersten Zugriff auf diese
riesigen Budgets die die russische Armee
bekommt und
das muss man halt abwarten aber also die
Friedenstauben die flattern nicht im
Gramm die sehe ich dann nicht
danke Herr Langhagen Gruß nach Münster
und dann gehen wir nach Gerstungen da
ist Karl-heinz Brack am Apparat hallo
Herr Brack
ja ein herzliches Hallo in die Runde und
mein Respekt Herr Schönbrunn für
brillante Motivation und erstklassige
Zusammenfassung ich verfolge den
pressetopf seit vielen Jahrzehnten und
meine Frage an die Runde
ist das nicht legitim dass ein
angegriffener der von einem pokalportal
ergressor mit diversen militärischen
Werkzeugen bedroht und auf schärfste
angegriffen wird auch alle Möglichkeiten
haben sollte sich zu verteidigen ich
nehme wahr das ständig eine Verschiebung
erfolgt welche Waffen denn nun möglich
sein und auch die Eingangsfrage legt er
es nahe welche Waffen dürfen geliefert
werden und ich kriegsbarkeit zu werden
ich meine
ein Verteidiger darf sich mit allen
Waffen verteidigen mit denen ihr
angegriffen wird und hier ist meine
Runde ist das nicht legitim
hätten sie gerne von einer bestimmten
Person eine Antwort frei Hildebrandt hat
schon Luft geholt soll ich ihr das Wort
erteilen
und das bestreitet ja auch niemand aber
es ist eben auch legitim dass man wenn
man selber dann in der Weise involviert
wird dass man dazu beiträgt dass man
sich damit beschäftigt welche
Nebenwirkungen das möglicherweise hat
und wie sich eben der glaube ich
wirklich von allen erwünschte Haupt die
von allen erwünschte Hauptwirkungen
nämlich dass Russland aus diesem Land
rausgeht ohne irgendein geländegewinner
erzielt zu haben wie sich das Abwägen
lässt also insofern sie haben völlig
Recht aber man kommt trotzdem mit diesem
Standpunkt nicht aus dem die Lehrer raus
dass man ununterbrochen diese Abwägung
machen muss welchen Risiko man sich
selbst aber aussetzt und das ist ja das
worauf Scholz dann auch immer abzielt
wenn er von seinem Amt als spricht und
dem er sich verpflichtet fühlt und das
ist natürlich auch das ist nicht von der
Hand zu weisen und das an der Stelle hat
er sich ja auch einen Punkt wenn er sagt
dass die Bevölkerung ist erwartet dass
man es sich schwer macht und zwar
wirklich schwer macht also nicht nur
dass man vorführt dass man sich schwer
macht sondern das nehme ich ihm schon ab
dass man wirklich diese Abwägung sehr
sehr
sorgfältig trifft Herr Prag danke
bleiben sie uns treu danke auch für die
Blumen Gruß nach Gerstungen jetzt sind
wir in der Nähe von Lindau
Weiler-Simmerberg Egbert frommknecht
hallo Herr Frank Knecht hallo guten Tag
in die Runde ich hätte eine Frage zum
Kommunikationsstil von Olaf Scholz
thematisiert wurde
natürlich
alle einig dass der kommunikationsspiel
von Olaf Scholz verbesserungsweg wäre
nur bin ich der Meinung dass gerade in
dieser Situation gerade zu optimal ist
nehmen wir zum Beispiel die Krim
angenommen Olaf Scholz wurde sagen es
unterstützen die Ukraine durch sich die
Wurzeln aus allen Gebieten
einschließlich der Krim zurückgezogen
haben dann wäre natürlich jegliche rote
Linie beseitigt und äh stolz müsste ja
praktisch dann auch jeglichen Daten
Wünschen der Ukraine Nachkommen
wollt ihr andererseits sagen nein
unterstützen du keine Uhr bis ich
wirklich die Russen hinter die Grenzen
vom 24 Februar zurückgezogen haben da
möchte ich nicht wissen wie am nächsten
Tag von dem Medien klein gehäkelt wird
allen voran wahrscheinlich nicht immer
Mann also meine Frage ist seitdem der
nicht gerade gar nichts anderes übrig
als so kommen zu kommunizieren hier ist
eben gerade tut
ja vielleicht muss man es davon abhängig
machen in welcher Phase wir uns gerade
befinden also gerne geht es jetzt
tatsächlich um eine kurzfristige
Entscheidung was die Panzer angeht oder
geht es um eine Definition
dessen was das Kriegsziel sein kann und
das sind zwar unterschiedliche
Diskussionen was höre ich richtig aus
aus Ihrer Frage zum Beispiel raus hat
die Ukraine ein Recht die Krim wieder
zurückzubekommen
ist das eine Diskussion die herr Scholz
führen sollte
er kann sie er kann sich an dieser
Diskussion beteiligen natürlich aber
zunächst hat die Ukraine jedes Recht
diese die Krim zurückzufordern und ob es
dann aber wirklich richtig ist sie mit
Waffengewalt zurückzuholen oder ob das
vielleicht eine eine Geschichte sein
könnte die ausgeklammert wird im Zuge
von Verhandlung also
da finde ich muss in jeder einzelnen
Stufe möglichst abgewogen werden aber
eben auch erklärt werden das ist man
kann nicht das eine tun ohne das andere
zu lassen
herr Frank wir hatten das in der Sendung
ja schon ne das ist so dass Dilemma wie
offen kann ein demokratisch gewählter
Regierungschef in einer Kriegssituation
seine Absichten erklären welche
Wirkungen welche Nebenwirkungen hat das
wobei sie haben vorhin gesagt erklären
und ich finde es gibt einen Unterschied
zwischen Beschreiben und begründen und
leider begründet er auch jetzt relativ
wenig er hat einige Interviews gegeben
seit er diese Entscheidung getroffen hat
und was er eigentlich macht ist dass er
darstellt was er tut aber im Grunde das
eigentlich wenig also die Frage warum
denn mit den Amerikanern wir versuchen
das dann alle zu durchdringen aber
gesagt hat das nicht danke nach Lindau
in Düsseldorf ist Vincenzo kalifano in
der Leitung willkommen in der Sendung
Herr kaliforno wir sind kurz vor Schluss
bin gespannt ja
frage einmal
warum denn 90% der Medien der Politik
von Manta an in diese militäre Logik
verfallen nicht während der äh die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung gegen diese Waffe
liefern sie presst und weltser als
Beispiel und die zweite Frage war ob die
Medien die einfach von NATO von diese
doktorische toxische atlantismus
finanziert sind oder die selber die
Wünsche der USA und der NATO erfüllen
bevor die Sie anrufen so warum diese
diese schräge demokratische
Widerspiegelung es ist ähm ja das war
meine kritische Frage warum ist es so
ist und dann höre letzte Woche auch
Beklagte also Eichhorn ich
glaube nicht dass es so ist
beispielsweise bei uns in der Berliner
Zeitung wir bilden da verschiedene
Positionen ab wir haben da Gastbeiträge
von Frau Wagenknecht von Wels haben wir
gesprochen die nehmen die sie ja auch
nannten und wir versuchen da beide
Seiten zu zeigen ich glaube nicht dass
es diese Art von Gleichheit und die sie
geschrieben haben gibt es gibt aber
natürlich auf der sachlich fachlichen
Ebene Argumente die ausgetauscht werden
und erzählen eben dann am Ende auch
nicht nur Meinung sondern was sagen die
Experten dazu und was ist die Lage
wirklich vor Ort deswegen ja ich würde
sozusagen ihrer grundkritik
grundsätzlichen Kritik widersprechen das
gibt's auch anders aber man muss am Ende
natürlich auch ja die Fakten reden
bedanke mich für diese Runde bedanke
mich für die vielen Einwürfe im Netz für
die vielen Anrufe ja wir sind in einer
Etappe eines langen Weges in diesem
Krieg und wir werden an diesem Tisch in
einer neuen anderen Situation weiter
sprechen danke dass Sie dabei sind einen
schönen Sonntag alles Gute
[Musik]
für die Tiere in der Wildnis geht es Tag
für Tag